thank you
okay
all right all right so welcome to
today's full council meeting
I've got apologies from councilor
cracker who's overseas and I have Trish
Boyle uh up there on Zoom she's not well
but she'll be back soon she tells me
um and the lead into today's meeting
um we've got a presentation by Great
South chair Ian Collier I have the
apologies accepted oh yes thank you
and so back to where I was
um
we have the chair of breaks out and to
give us an update on the oak milk
um
in New Zealand functional foods
situation with the law not being in
South London any longer as a lead into
that I've just got a couple things to uh
to update people on for those that are
listening in
so
um
you'll see here we've got Ian who's the
chair and Charming who's about to wave
her hand and she's the chief executive
so the operational side of great sound
so great South followed on from the
previous Economic Development agency
which was Venture South on
um
that goes back quite some time
the current organization provides a
range of outcomes predominantly funded
by Council but also by government and
other funders as well and they include
the development of Beyond 2025 plan
which includes tourism climate change
industry diversification Workforce
Development housing and a whole range of
other things so about 14th Street
strategic issues for us we have one of
four councils at part funds the
organization and other funding comes
from specific areas that want uh one-off
outcomes as well
so just as a bit of a back view for
people who don't know
um
that um
as I said Venture cell phone with the
organization that preceded this so This
New Zealand functional food goes back to
the previous era so it goes back and
somebody can clarify for me later on 10
or 12 years
and the primary
outcome that was delivered at the time
was to diversify away from primary
industry so it was an effort to try the
oats was an F try and diversifying in
the agricultural sector
the oak grain or the oak grain milk has
come along part way through there
so we have
an oat milk that was intended to be
built here
but as capital was needed other
investors have come into the play so the
company is currently k1w1 which is the
Stephen Tyndall Foundation
owned company they are 51 percent
and the combined councils are 49 so that
makes us a minority shareholder and
there are implications of being a
minority shareholder
as the capital has been needed to be
raised for the mill and the figures up
in excess of 100 million dollars other
investors have come to the table and of
course anybody that's been in business
will know when you bring capital or
investors into the table the Dynamics of
the shareholding changes and so it was
my understanding that it was never the
intention of Great South to be involved
with the capital raise that was needed
so there would be a dilution of our
shareholding in the company as the
company went forward
so from where I see at the moment as the
major shareholder which is k1w1 and some
International
funders got together and did the due
diligence they made a decision
that the best place for the oatmeal was
not here
now there'll be some things that Ian
canner can't say about that given that
he's still represents Us in the company
um so some will still be commercially
sensitive because that's not that whole
relationship isn't finalized yet
um but certainly there's a need
for us to understand why and rangi put
up a quite rightly put up a notice of
motion asking
I've actually help people come to the
table today and so we can get some
answers but we won't get all the answers
that we might hardly leave
and for Rob who's here
um who's the
mayor of the southern district and also
the chair of the stakeholders group he's
here as an observer and Stuart collie's
also here and he's got his uh background
in The Growers area as well so hopefully
we'll get a few ounces today and certify
some but not probably not all
so Ian if you'd like to come forward
we'll bring China with you if yonding
so we've got we've got a reasonable
process for today which I've outlined to
everybody being mindful this is not the
normal way that we would do business I
guess
um for Great South that would normally
be in a different function through the
stakeholders but quite open to having
the notification that we had so the
floor is yours ringing
oh it's me oh thank you I thought we
were getting a presentation for me about
no no straight to me is it oh sorry well
no no no no you can do it that way if
you want to you no no I'm I'm happy to
start him because you know it's it's
just certain questions and then okay all
reopen Hi Ian hi shami
um look I I guess everyone I'll start
with the uh Beyond 2025 announcement in
June everything's looking fantastic 70
new jobs oatmeal being produced out at
macarawa
so that was in June and then then I
guess in July I'm reading a
TV One News online article and um
there's comments from both yourself and
Paul Harvey
about the relocation
of the oat milk plant to uh Canterbury
and
uh the the statements made by both of
you
um highlight uh the reasons why now I I
guess that and I thought well that's not
a bad way to start with questions now
Paul stated that for the success of the
greater Vision it is vital that our
planned manufacturing base is in the
location that allows easy connection and
collaboration with industry and
infrastructure so my question to that is
what what does Southland
not have
in Kiev for a structure
um that that is missing that that would
do that considering we have the Edendale
fonteras here we have all sorts of
factories and stuff that are thriving
so I'll start with that question first
can you answer that on Paul's behalf or
you know I can probably
um answer some of that for you in terms
of
um but not all of it it's just one of
the reasons why it's been relocated and
I think you know if I could sort of um
summarize the the weird I think Paul has
been was coming from at that point is
the potential investor in this project
made a conscious decision at a point in
time that the uh the criteria for the
location of the of the plant didn't suit
it was better suited elsewhere
um and they they're entirely entitled to
make that decision
um and so and that's the decision they
ultimately made okay so when you say the
investor as of today when you look on uh
the the company's register uh there's
only the same two shareholders in New
Zealand functional picks yeah sorry I'm
just if I could just clarify that so so
nzf is the effectively the vehicle
through raising the capital
um and and it's the and it's nzf's role
to go out to the market to seek
investment for the development of the
plant the scope of the plant changed has
changed radically from where it started
and um and to be honest the the
potential investor has brought a lot to
the table in that respect and what they
were looking for what where we started
in that conversation and with regards to
the scope of the plant changed
dramatically from where where it started
and in their View and in the investors
view anywhere we're talking about
potential because this is still in
negotiation
that in their view
um the there was Canterbury at that
point is a better is better location for
the plant
and and that's something they're
entirely entitled to do what the the
point that you made about the um the
commentary that we made at the 2025
launch
um was it was where we sat at that point
and timing for us was not good
it certainly wasn't good for us and not
ideal for anybody from a Southland
perspective and I absolutely acknowledge
that that um the statements that we were
making which was around the potential
and it was about the potential of the
plant being being built here
um and for that not to be realized is
hugely disappointing I totally
acknowledge that right so so
so they're not actually shareholders at
all they are like a bank effectively an
investor
of course so nzf
is the company that was formed to raise
the capital
for to raise Capital to build the plant
and an investor coming in and looking at
the scope of that at the scope of the
project and so their role is to attract
investment for that project and the
scope of the project is growing
dramatically from that point and what
I'm talking and so and so we have
attracted a Cornerstone so we they have
attracted a Cornerstone of investor
potential investor
and and through their due diligence they
made a decision that it would the plant
was better located elsewhere in
Southland okay right so our intent was
always to have it built in Southland
okay so absolutely the intent from a
great South perspective I just want to
get clear about the different entities
that we're talking about right so so did
the board
um I see there's three directors on the
border of nzfu yeah so did that board
have to make a decision to
to shift it's I mean the board would
have the ultimate say wouldn't it
yes it would and obviously the board
made a decision you
that did okay so uh the the shear split
is 51 with k1w1 and 49 with great South
um
so I looked at the constitution of
nzf and it talks about a shareholders
agreement now
um but but it doesn't that's not
publicly available the shareholders
agreement but it's quite common
uh with companies that initial holders
agreement there is a clause that
for any major decision like the
relocation of a plant you need all
shareholders agreement or the major
shareholders agreement so great South as
a shareholder of nzdff if
was it required to give consent
and if so did it
well what what I can say is that great
South supported a resolution of nzff
um so the Great South token position to
support the resolution passed by nzf if
not to locate the plant here okay well I
just want to go to now to Great South
Constitution
and section 2.1 it says that the Egypt
the objectives of the company are to and
I'll go straight to C conduct a business
in the best interest of Southland in
accordance with Sound business practice
and then D following that exhibit a
sense of Social and environment
responsibility by having regards to the
interests of the Southland community in
which the company operates now was great
South in supporting this being true to
its Constitution we we absolutely
believe we were yes
well
and there was no fight to say hey we
started off with a with a with a the
idea of a milk factory here look I'll
move on from that because I could if I
could just edit it so as a 49
shareholder in nzf it is absolutely an
end under our constitution in our shared
agreement absolutely it is in our best
it is in our best interests and and we
are obligated to act in the best
interests of Southland and when I say
absolutely we support we did support it
and we supported the resolution that was
taken that's because we have a 49
shareholding in in something that is
worth something those shares have a
value attached to them what the value of
those shares is and whether whether
that's realized is is
um is still under negotiation
um in so it's important in the decision
that we made was to ensure that we
protected the value of those shares on
the way through that negotiation and
brought it to a conclusion where we got
a return on that on that investment that
had been made when I say it had been
made it's important to note that the 49
shareholding we had and I go back
further in time on that it was derived
from a vision that we had about an oat
milk plant I wasn't part of that but I
was party to it and have been over the
last four years
as chair of the great CF board so it's
important that we in at a point in time
through nzf
that Vision attracted a second
shareholder being k1w1 who took out 51
shareholding
and have since put the capital in
necessary to raise the funds in order
for us to build that plant
so it's very important to understand the
nature of that because there is a value
attached to the shares that we have so
ultimately the decision that we make and
then the best interests of Southland is
to one the right to get a return on the
on the value of those shares if we can
and we believe that is in the best
interests of Southland and then two to
also make sure that we're looking after
the best interests of the other investor
who has put hard cash and invested
heavily in this and remembering it is a
startup
and any Star anyone that's been involved
with the startup business will
appreciate the challenges that come with
that
so it's never a straight line
that brings its challenges okay I've got
three three more questions in there
quite quite quick
um
right another comment from Paul
in that uh in that interview with TV One
news he says the Southland story will be
a key part of our future and we have
strong intention to continue to partner
with Growers across the region now
um this apparently from what I'd heard
this new plant with the new investors is
going to be a state of the art green is
green can be type plant now the idea the
concept of tracking oats from Southland
all the way to Canterbury doesn't sound
like a green idea and especially it I
work out eighty dollars a ton
um to get it there now how was that
statement
you know how is that real how can that
be real for The Growers of of Southland
well I think you need to go to the again
um so you need to go to the investor
that is a question for those that invest
in this project and believe that they
can make it economically and viable for
a grower to to truck or to transport
those oats
um to the point where they are milled
and turned into evaluated product that's
that's a question for them they are they
are absolutely certain they can do it
even within with the carbon footpreneur
they're confident that they can do it
and so that's something that again that
is not a question that from a great
South perspective
um there I can't answer that okay and
I'm not trying to avoid the question
it's a simple one for the for those that
are investing in it they may they need
to make it an economically viable from
the farm gate and the good news is that
there are Growers
there is a Consortium of Growers there
is interest in this the in the in in
South and outs are the best in the world
they will continue to be the best in the
world from our perspective the
nutritional and protein value of them
hasn't won't change in fact it should
even improve and so we should be very
optimistic about that if they believe
they can do it economically and that we
they can deliver a a positive and
profitable return to the farm gate then
that's something that would be that's
something we should support right I'll
go back to I talk about Stuart Nash now
and a year ago he announced a six
million dollar
government-backed loan
uh for out of the Strategic Regional
strategic partnership fund to give to
nzf now this I just read about the fund
the 200 million dollar fund aims to grow
Regional economies by helping people
develop projects specific to their
community so obviously
if I'm right and thinking that this six
million dollars is for Southland and the
fact that it would not be transferred to
a plant in Canterbury because that no
longer a regional is that true
well that's a question that you have to
ask central government
it's not something that I can answer in
terms of carnoa funding what I can say
is that the objective from the beginning
was where that six million dollar
um assessment whether it came in equity
or debt I'm not you know that's that's
accomplished yes it is it's a loan it's
a loan yeah and so that that
conversation came from the just
transition process through the um the
EOG
um form and it was supported by us
obviously from a great South perspective
I think the two things to note there is
and and that conversation that continues
with kanoa
um through uh nzf directly to see
whether they will continue to support
that and provide that loan to Canterbury
that's a conversation that they need to
they need to have and that they're
having
and from our perspective though from a
Southland perspective it's important to
note that it's and I'm not trying to be
cute here that it's called New Zealand
functional foods not South and
functional foods
the investor that we're talking to has a
global reach
central government has an opportunity
central government will be looking after
the interests of the NZ Inc that
includes Us in all other regions and so
they will put that into the mix when
they decide whether or not to provide
that loan that loan Finance to uh
through to nzf or through ultimately to
the to that investor or investors and
remembering that there are other
co-investors
that that
um we'll be looking at this opportunity
not just one so so ultimately the
government will decide on the future
it's a government decision yeah okay my
last question before I hand back to
genobi is
um so it was December 2020 where
um
Great South
did the new share issue that increased
the shears to 2 million and then created
the 5149 split with k1w1 so it was in
December 2020. now
was it did it seek approval from the
joint shareholders committee to do that
Great South
when it looked effectively lost
shareholder control did it
obviously it was approved by the Great
South board but did it go through the
shareholder joint share holidays
committee uh I I'm confident that we did
yes
there would be a record of that and the
shareholders committee would have
approved that yeah no I need to you just
need to leave that with me
okay but I'm confident that we sought
the right approvals to actually
undertake that undertake that
transaction yes so in your in your
statement of intent there's a section
there that's quite clear that
you can't
increase investment and things without
coming back to the to the joint
committees but there's nothing stopping
you doing what what you did you know and
and diluting your shares effectively so
my last question is
besides right beside this piece on on
page 50 on NZ and fifth is space Ops now
what what protection do we have that
space Ops this doesn't happen to space
Ops that suddenly
um we find that it's been bought by the
shareholders being you know someone's
got 60 now someone from another country
or something what's what gives this
Council a sort of bitter protection that
this couldn't happen without it going
right up to the so I know before you
comment on it Ian I don't want you to
comment on that I've already signaled to
my elected members that issues around
how we invest or don't invest in
cctos is for further discussion not
today no this is just sorry sorry
um you worship this is purely just
comparing space Ops with what happened
with
um New Zealand functional foods it's the
same thing
I've got on the agenda
uh okay with the chair of the
shareholders was just sitting behind us
here
uh if if if if there is a concern with
regards to the decision-making processes
that the board undertake I can
absolutely commit uh to this audience
that
um we are at the we we're very confident
that the processes and the boundaries uh
we understand our accountabilities we uh
we're very comfortable with the and the
relationship that we have with our
shareholders through the through the
chair uh who I talked to almost daily
um for on a variety of issues that those
protections are in place
okay absolutely confident and
comfortable with it uh Mr chair
okay
um thank you yeah you're welcome thank
you Ian so I've got some questions and
I'm going to throw it over near you
um just one for me I got a a late night
call when the decision was made to move
them all away
from you
and I think your initial reaction to me
was
um subject to Great South board uh
decision that you'd pull away from
functional foods so that told me that
you're fairly angry I guess about the
decision that had transport
is it a fear assumption I think that
would be a mild way of saying it uh Mr
chair yes yeah so it was it was hugely
disappointing yeah at the same time we
have to we had to put our decision into
the context of of the project uh where
it was where it could go and and again
in the best interests of Southland
okay
I've done some homework on that so I'll
share that shortly
Tom
who I might add it was the chair of
venture Southland no it was not a chair
I was a director Adventure Southland
sorry this project got underway I think
10 years ago
um and my recollection was that the
purpose of the project was to support
diversification of agriculture
in Southland obviously specifically oats
in this case
um the plant itself the milk plant was
seen as an enabler for that
so it was never
um the fundamental purpose of the
project it was to enable you know an
increase in the the growing of oats in
Southland
so the extent to which
um you know the it may end up in in
Canterbury
the extent to which that is uh a
negative for the whole project it really
depends on whether the cost savings and
the benefits are having it in Canterbury
outweighed increased transport costs of
getting the oats up there
and you know that's going to be a
commercial negotiation between the oak
Growers and the my understanding is New
Zealand functional foods will still
require Southland oats
so they're going to get because you know
it's the best dog growing area and in
New Zealand they're still going to
require
Southland doors and they're going to
have to get up there by some way again
does it does the efficiency of the
process plant being in Canterbury
outweigh the additional transport costs
in fact another question is whether does
a transport of Oats caused outweigh the
transport of water
because you get a transport an awful lot
of water when you when you make oat milk
um and it's going to end up in a sense
of population
I think to the fact that you know tyo
you mean them do not produce aluminum
ladders
because it just costs too much money to
transport air
you know to send us a population so
processing plants further processing
plants unfortunately tend to be located
is sent as a population
rather than where the premier producer
is so although although this is
unfortunate outcome I think
um it doesn't surprise me at all and I
and I would just add that
um you if you look at the swords action
plan which was done two years into this
project the oatmeal plant is not
mentioned at all
and the reason for that is because when
it was looked up back then
um by the group that was looking at new
Industries and the group who was looking
at agriculture they thought that it was
too low probability it being built here
so uh I guess a little bit of compliment
um I think the fact that Great South
took it from being something that swords
actually see that's never going to
happen so that is something where it
almost did
you know deserves actually a lot of
compliment because it was I think
personally think it was probably always
a long shot to get the processing plant
here but fundamentally the purpose of it
is to get more oats grown in South
London I will tell any a question Ian
um I mean and and you know your view to
the extent we can judge it at this point
is that actually gonna meet the factors
in Canterbury is that going to be a
significant negative to having an
increase in oh it's grown in Southland
are they all still going to be grown
here
I think
so it is a good question and
again it is you know forgive me for
making some assumptions
the
the fact there is no question in my mind
based on you know and I have some you
know I do have the privilege of sitting
at the table and getting as close to it
as we possibly can whilst the
negotiations continue that South and
Oates play a pivotal role as does a
prominent story around them about
Southland and and the investors are
absolutely intent on having Southland
play its part in this as much as we can
if the plant without the plant
physically being here
second part so the answer is yes
absolutely in a high degree you know and
you know probably around 75 percent
of those oats
um and the diversification of land and
that the objective of that has not
changed from day one it still exists it
still exists for us it is a key part of
our plan as a region to look at land
diversification
and so this still plays a part in that
and the oats growing here and the
quality of them and getting having a
having a Consortium of Growers that are
absolutely connected to this and and
believe in it I think that that's it
it's not just a pipe dream I think that
that is reality the bigger play here as
well is what will we be growing here in
15 or 20 years time
because it's not getting colder
and so we don't we can't answer that but
what I can say is that the ecosystem if
you like that the investors are looking
at building which is World leading
um and it is out there it's around
around food and fiber evaluated products
to take but not just to the New Zealand
Market to the world is hugely exciting
and I'm saying that from a south
southern perspective let alone from a
regional Canterbury New Zealand Inc
perspective and it is a we are at a
point in time where we have the
opportunity to play our part in that so
it's not limited to oats but at the same
time it came from the oak story and I
think that's something we need to be
incredible we are incredibly proud of
and that we will we will continue to be
playing a part in that in that and on
your point about the economic viability
as I mentioned before it's investors are
confident that they can make that work
and some of that will be about getting
gaining efficiencies through the through
the manufacture process which we don't
we don't have visibility of currently
with they do
because they're coming from a Global
Perspective so New Zealand has an
opportunity here to set a framework and
set a plant and a standard here that is
we'll set a new standard for at a global
level and it and I'm not just
that that is the reality of what we're
dealing with here and it's not limited
to oats it's other plant-based products
other crops and that on that point uh uh
time that's that's about what other
thing what else can we derive from this
which is beneficial to Southland that's
that is not just about oats what else is
there that we can do but through the
byproducts that are created that may be
able to feed into other industries that
we have here in Southland that's that's
an exciting proposition as well
because you're you're right this is a
this is about zero waste
of a zero waste proposition
thank you
another questions
Leslie
thank you Ian just um just a very simple
question
without an outsider and without an
outsider investor
would the plant ever have been built
cool
um
in Southland or just generally or
anywhere I mean the idea 10 years ago we
all thought was great
without an outside independent investor
would it ever have become more than a
vision would we ever have had the plant
built well I think ultimately just
because of the amount of investment
required it will it requires you know
some serious investment and so the
answer is probably
um I I don't know I honestly don't know
I think we've got an idea we came to a
vision that was a vision strong enough
to to attract and invest a a
shareholding 51 shareholder through an
incredibly credible
investor who has the same who shares
that vision and then that's then gone on
and attracted others so without that you
know that's the that's the reality that
we're dealing with
and we're now on a time frame where
we're getting closer to the point of
reality and um I would never say that
it's it's a given because it's nothing
is it's it's a negotiation so that was
my next question at the moment
it's not yet a reality no it's not
um it's a continued it has a continued
negotiation and again I'd sort of go
back to my comment about a startup
business that anybody has been involved
with the startup knows that the you know
the the campus can move at any point at
any time and through no control of your
own
um or those that are looking to invest
either what I will say is that the due
diligence that this that the investors
are doing is intense
and so it should be because it's an in
excess of 100 million dollars and it's
not that's not a small amount of change
it's a serious project and the good news
is as I say I I look at the likes of
k1w1 with Stephen Tyndall and his team
who are hugely supportive of this and
that in itself gives me Comfort and they
continue to be supportive of it and
we're closer to coming to reality now
than we were
so we're closer to the end of the
beginning than we than we were
and and the transport option question
I'm presuming investors of this caliber
are looking at Coastal shipping looking
at Railway they'll be looking at all
alternative
um
ear Freight
all of the options but as I say at the
end of the day they they uh you know to
attract the investors that we're looking
for
um they will be looking at all of that
in the economics around that get the
yolks from one point to another
economically and again
um with the least less carbon footprint
how do you do that
and you're pretty well giving us the
assurance that the Oaths intended to be
the majority of what goes through the
plant uh
thank you
brilliant well thank you Mr me thank you
Ian and xiaomi for coming along today
um
following on from what
um ringy and Tom have mentioned
I guess from my perspective 2013 14 15
16 17 up to today
um the oats have been as you said
considered as a startup business
um we are we all knew from day dot that
this potential well-being and health
medical enhancement product could be the
absolute diversification about
agriculture industry here in Southland
so guess where I'm coming to I
understand that
um major investors have been sought and
why NZ if it was started that's a
no-brainer really
probably from from
my understanding of what you've
delivered what we've read and what we've
shared in Communications is that
fundamentally
that investment for the startup business
would not have been attractive had the
plant not have been accessed on a
national and potentially a global market
here in invercargill that is why
fundamentally the plant has been
identified as being shifted to
Canterbury because it has a better
maximization of business and economic
um benefits to our country therefore the
knock-on effect would be back down here
to invercargill to the Oak Grove
am I understanding that quickly
if I'm going to sum it up just like that
yeah ultimately as a yeah ultimately
those that are looking to invest who are
making conscious decisions about what
yeah everything to do with that plant
the construct of the plant in including
the location so they go through their
own criteria great they're given all of
the information that we can possibly
give them and again there are some
assumptions that are made in those in
those calculations uh but they they
would it is their role to undertake
their due diligence they look at all
aspects of the of the project and the
potential it has and then they make a
decision whether we put the dollar in or
we don't sure so we we don't really
control it but what we have what we did
do is attract I you know a a shareholder
um to assist us to to cash flow this
project to the point where we got a
Cornerstone investor and other
co-investors does that answer your
question yeah it does some some of them
but that's fine my other final question
is this can you accept
um given
the development of having the plant
moved away from invercargill to
Canterbury can you accept the
uh disappointing disappointment to our
City that this has bought the news
brought to our city that has been moved
away can you accept that that has been
disappointing
absolutely understand that and I share
it
totally thank you
right
yeah thanks cheer um and thanks
um Ian and chummy for coming along
um I'm interested in the business case
from the investors perspective
I'm sitting here looking at a
newsletter from
um on Oates report window 22 which says
the the actual investment case for
Farmers to change land use is is minimal
if non-existent
in terms of the returns They will
receive yes so other investors or the
potential investing your founder there
were they they're cute they're aware
absolutely as you'd expect them to be
right so you know the price at the farm
gate the cost to get to the mill
um or the price paid to to get them to
the mill all of that is taken into
account and and I would fully expect
them to be
so so in sort of reviewing their
investment case
are they forecasting greater returns at
Farmgate to which would lead Farmers to
continue to supply out or diversify out
of other land uses and meet the scale
capacity that they're talking about in
Canterbury yeah I think I think again
it's
some of it for me to answer that
question
um I think that yes I think that they're
absolutely doing their sums any investor
that's working with is doing their sums
to to qualify it and make sure that they
can deliver a return to the grower one
thing I would also say and again I'm not
an expert in growing folks and there's
many people that can speak a better
better about that than me what I have
learned through this is that the amount
of land required the volume of milk that
can be produced from a small land area
is phenomenal and so the amount of land
exchange you know the amount of transfer
of land from what from you know from one
crop or one type of farming to another
for to move to an outspace the land
required is is a lot less than I had
anticipated I thought it was a massive
area and it's not which is a huge thing
so you can deliver a hell of a lot from
a small area and in terms of the tonnage
and again the quality quality we know is
there so I think that's that sort of you
have to get that into the mix as well in
terms of what the relativity of this in
terms of land diversification relative
to other
types of farming other crops
um livestock whatever that might be yeah
because I mean from a pharmaceutical
perspective there has to be a commercial
return absolutely yeah and that's one of
the reasons why south of the notes are
so good because of the cooler days the
milk the content is significantly more
than it is Canterbury oats and and the
other thing is looking at the
we with our heads on we look at it from
an oat milk perspective and I put my hat
on as a customer of of oat milk and what
the price point is you know I go I go
and purchase that
um this is not just about oat milk this
is about what else what other products
are there what what else can you do with
it what are the other byproducts what
can we where's the value add in that and
that's where the exciting piece actually
is and that's what we've been introduced
to in terms of all the other aspects of
this and on Tom's Point
um it's also about
you know so what ultimately if this is a
southern story and and the investors are
admitted to making sure that we we play
a critical role in this then what does
that look like and what what are those
byproducts and what can we do and what
what part can we play in it going
forward that may not necessarily be
directly related to oh so it could be
another industry where those byproducts
are used because that those are the
those are the things that are now been
or those are the solutions that are now
being found at a global level but we we
haven't had visibility of that's
exciting
so seeking just for me so now putting
your head on is the shareholder investor
yes
the the returns that you've seen
so because what I take out of what
you've shared is that there's an
opportunity here to make an actual
return on the information
yeah are you able to indicate what sort
of level of return that would be not at
this point is it minimal
right
give you some indication you've reviewed
that what I can say is the decision to
actually stay in this and to remain part
of this is
that is part of it but obviously as part
of that in terms of making sure that we
get a return on the on that on the
shares that we have in the company
thank you
yeah thank you Mr Mia
I've I've learned a lot over
50 years in business
I'll be involved with a lot of
businesses small some very small some
very large
and I found out the hard way that if you
haven't got control over the
shareholding you start from behind the
eight ball simple as that
and
I just wonder why others were allowed to
hold 51 in this company
look for over 25 years
our city have invested a lot into um
Great South into South and prior and now
Great South
and I believe that we are not getting
bang for our buck
and I'm annoyed very annoyed and very
disappointed
that employment opportunities
have been lost for a lot of selflessness
that's all I have to say thank you uh
Ian you don't need to answer anything to
that thank you
compania
Oh no you're okay
um
my question really is you talked about
land diversification
I wouldn't
care to Hazard against it to What
proportion of land previously had been
used for growing oats but
in general there has been a lot of
grains grown in this area so
what sort of extra potential of growth
was there perceived to be in this or was
it more that the diversification was
actually the product of the oats
given that we already grow oats we
already grow
other grains so is it that there was an
increased proportion or a diversity of
what
oats were used for
or both I think it's a mixture of both
it's about growing the volume and also
and also the potential for you know for
where that where does it go from there
in terms of what we're producing from
those from The Oaks
so as a follow-up to that
you haven't stopped looking at what
other Downstream product could come from
an increased growth of Oats is that the
same for wheat or barley or other grains
or is it specifically oats that's there
well it's that it started with the oak
story and that is actually that is still
the Cornerstone of the of the project
that still remains that from our
perspective it does
when I talked about the scope of the
project it has broadened a lot from
where from where it started and into
other crops
um and other products that um you know I
don't want to I can't really comment
much more than that
no thank you I just I just needed to get
my head around what
you know proportionality
more oats but also more opportunity
definitely thank you
ringy
thanks chair uh look this question's
really about bookkeeping Viewpoint from
Great South shareholders and nzff was
um formed in September 2014.
and obviously we had the the new
shareholder coming in December 2020. up
until I was point that six years does
Great South
have a record of the investment that
both in manners and and capital and
everything that's been put in the nzf
before k1w1 came on board
there's Great Sound you know that should
be I mean in your running running great
South you there should be an allocation
of people's time and stuff yeah well
remember we were we went to the we went
to the letter of expectation that we
received from the council and we and and
we're apply our resources to that
um in saying that for this particular
project what I would say is
um yes to a degree
um and I but I think yeah tell us how
much I can't tell you off the top of my
head no Brandy but what I would say is
that the information a lot of the data
that we would use for this project would
be applicable to others as well there's
a lot of transferable data around that
land use the land type soil types Etc
that we would use for multiple for
multiple reasons so it's hard to well
just to narrow down say where their
trips overseas whether trips overseas by
staff
related to oat milk
prior to my time I I couldn't I can't
but if we if we asked and and Charming
put the question to show me absolutely
can you do a breakdown of those six
years what potentially
um as shareholders
we've committed
yeah yeah yeah but that's something that
possibly could be done thank you
Mary
yeah um with the 5149 sharehold
um we've got uh 49
is there any
possibility that airside of it will be
deleted down
by other people coming in well it will
it will be
um you know subject to the investment
the investors coming in then our
shareholding will be diluted that's
correct yes but it would be relative to
the the investment being made and the
total value of the project
so it's still it's still relative
um it's and we'd still extract the
return from that
yeah Leslie
thank you Mr chair Ian I'm just
interested
the intellectual property yes where does
it sit
good question
um so there is so the the intellectual
property that we believe we brought into
this is where the value that k1w saw and
invested in since then
um I would say that there's been a
significant shift that the investors
have brought in their own IP into this
into this process
um but that is all wrapped up in the
negotiation and the term sheets that
will be negotiated now so I can't really
comment directly in terms of where where
the ownership of that lies the
percentage of that lies it wouldn't be
appropriate to answer yeah but what you
can but what I can say is that we you
know the IP effectively the intellectual
property that we we believe we had is
where k1w want what they invested in
effectively and it is and then from that
point attracting other investors that
believe that believe that they're
bringing in their own IP then that
changes the balance
um and to what degree is through as part
of that negotiation and the the
groundbreaking IP that has been 10 years
in the making is a significant part even
as a 49
shareholder we still hold in our view
thank you yes that that was my feeling I
just wanted to yeah to have your view on
that so so that is an important part of
the negotiations now and in the future
as other investors as it always is
was a it's always a sensitive subject an
intellectual property and any other
developments that might come from in the
future we would be protecting air share
of the intellectual property that's part
of the negotiation right thank you
just in regards to the the investors and
the increasing investors over time and I
can see with the benefits will be for
them what about we with the starter with
the community funds that were reported
from the beginning to support this what
sort of community benefits will come
back here
foreign
[Music]
of our growth development I know we're
talking about land and and increasing
out there about what about the community
the flow through to throw the flow
through to the community I think that's
where some of the you know the the
greatest disappointment sets in terms of
you know it not be if it's not located
here we don't have the employment here
for the plant itself
um then you know that's the flow on it
um but in terms of um in terms of the
question that you raised uh Evelyn
around
um the volume of Oats growing you know
there is just how that how that
translates
um I can't I can't it's hard to quantify
what that will look like our role is to
make sure that we get that we do get
that flow on effect economically you
know the economic environmental and
social outcomes are as best as we can
get relative to the decision that's been
made to locate it elsewhere we can't do
any more than that but to quantify it
it's not an easy
yeah and I understand that but I you
know I'm also in the mindset that you
know for our community the
disappointment
is there anything that we can sort of
like hang on to or
create where there will be benefit
around grants or something back to the
community from this initiative yeah I
think I think that have the flow on
effect of that is um depending on what
position that we take we end up having
with the business or not once it gets
over the line so we assume it goes over
the line and we and and it proceeds
um then that is that that will change
the conversation about you know where
where to from here what is in it for
South London
what else what other benefits can we
derive from it
that that to me is quite an exciting
prospect of having that conversation
yeah because the reality is it wouldn't
be here be existing without it at the
beginning and at the same time though we
you know it's hard to lose something
that we don't have oh absolutely because
we you know we we could have had this we
don't have it um but we're disappointed
that we that it's not going to be here
this one we're not looking at creation
what can we create yes and that that's
where the opportunity sits
thank you Tom
obviously in this project is
um
you know
it goes from the growing of the oats
through transport of those to a plant
the processing the goats in that plant
products being made that then get
shipped probably shipped to markets
International markets
so you would assume that our rational
investor
would choose the location plant location
that would optimize all of those things
so my question to you is whether you've
seen enough of the data and Analysis
that you understand the decision and
there's a difference between
understanding and supporting right we'd
all love to have
you know the plant here that would be
you know the cherry and the oak cake as
it were but
but have you seen enough at the
um that analysis that you can you
understand why the decisions being taken
yeah right just on my um my intellectual
capability
the answer is yes I think the rationale
that they're bringing to the what they
bring to the table is is
they absolutely understand what they're
doing they're hugely committed to it and
I think that it does stack up
and again they're looking at not just a
an oatmeal plant they're looking at
building an entire ecosystem around us
which involves other you know bringing
attracting other industry and other
other
um organizations to their to where they
are and that's all that has got momentum
and that's exciting
so I'm going to suggest share that I I
think some of the disappointment that
everybody feels
is probably based on the fact that some
of that analysis or the optimum location
of the plant might have been done
earlier
um I think if we had understood that it
might be that we had would have been
prepared ourselves for
this outcome
and because again I mean it does not
surprise me at all I mean it was what
swords thought would happen actually we
not looked at it back a few years ago so
uh so I I think people get excited by
processing plants because they're just
fundamentally sexier than growing oats
right so again it gets a lot of
attention I think it's all that
stainless steel
I guess I guess of a lot of I guess a
lot of attention but again coming back
to the fundamental purpose was to you
know diversify agriculture on Southland
it was it was not to bring not to to
build a plant initially
so that being the last question and that
being the shortest team in the public
forum we've ever had uh I'll just give a
quick overview on what what I've been
able to glean because I'm not quite as
uh constrained as Ian might be with his
different roles
um
I've met recently with sir Tyndall
um and when you look at the eye watering
Innovation startups that he does he
doesn't do them in a rational way he's
very clear in what he invests in
success rate very high so he doesn't get
the whole standard two out of three
falling over
um and he gave me some information that
I can't share but it gives me a peace of
mind
I've also met with the uh investor
that's overseas as well and can tell you
that they've got impressive Visions
around uh plant-based Foods
and around
um healthy foods so they're in it for
the long game as well and prepared to
put significant money on it
um
I think the overseas investors are
wanting to control the media now going
forward
um because it's a much bigger picture
than just what's happening here and so
they want to have some control of that
um I think the questions before about
the Returns on the shares
um from my perspective there's a medium
a medium return not low but not high so
if you think about our 49 and if we
stayed in the company for two three
whatever number of years it is what
shares will we end up in if we don't put
any money in well I'm no rocket
scientist about this but you'd assume
it'll be two three four percent
potentially and what's that is worth it
is open to open to negotiation but from
my quick analysis of of the financial
figures of what great South might have
put in
or and beat yourself and before put into
this project by way of a staff hours I
guess and you work out what our shares
will be worth we'll be on the right side
of the Ledger with that I think
so it gives you a bit of an
understanding
um
and so that's what I've been able to
glean by talking to people
um uncomfortable that the Mill's not
here but comfortable that it's in a
impressive projects going forward
and the good side of it is it does
portray uh
uh Great South as a good development
tool That Others May subsequently want
to use in the future and say well we've
got some I guess some expertise even
though we didn't get there
uh outcome that we particularly wanted
and the process going through as Tom
quite really said his don't know what
it's set out to do
um hasn't got the final stage that we
would have wanted
um but that doesn't mean that there
can't be further developments so thank
you for your time today
um and and Rob sit here if I could just
call me
um that you just made a comment
regarding the
um the investor wanting to control the
media I just want to qualify that and
say they want to control the comms well
that's what that's what that's what I'm
saying I think I'm just trying to make
sure yeah I think one of them you heard
it from some of the discussion today I
think the media or the comms around the
announcement was not good so in
politically correct
um it could have been done better so um
so I guess I want to make sure it is
better
so you're free to go
and thank you for your time and Rob did
you did you want to contribute anything
plus years ago when a great idea was um
really really successful with the best
as well as about 110 million dollars and
we don't have that level of investor and
sampling well there and I think also
reflecting on to as well I'm glad to
point about that
being built this outfit and I think
initially we're not just going to be
open and we're going down that road and
building an open maps of example it's a
couple of things with that bag of vision
and Rebecca back yet and back to Memphis
vacation Beyond just us that kind of
makes sense to have something in
Canterbury so I I hope that
differentiation between supporting and
understanding is quite a key one I I
totally understand the legal
disappointment I have with myself but I
also understand the position that we're
in and I think we need to celebrate
where we've actually gone through like
the process of rats out and
knowing that the board as well and some
of the creative comics like previous
comments about um how these decisions
being made we've got a very good skills
both here with a great cheer as well and
I think having that kind of see that
that sits outside of outside but inside
local government that has actually a
huge asset as well where we've got that
expertise and experience for most of
these decisions
yeah thanks for that
thank you for your time thank you thank
you thank you
five minute break guys before we uh go
back into business as usual get our head
to clear of what we just heard
a cup of tea or toilet for the old man
we're all back live now thank you
so we just got uh
continue on now with their meeting and
yeah
a suite of minutes to be accepted so the
first one is the uh minutes of the
council meeting held on the 22nd of
August
[Music]
any discussions
minutes of the infrastructure meeting on
the 5th of September
and that includes
um the recommendations uh the road
stopping and disposal of
a bigger Street and also the roads
stopping at Green Point
thank you for that seeing goodbye
bearing thank you any further
discussions including those
recommendations Council
I carried
extraordinary meeting of the bluff
community board held on the 11th of
September
Barry thank you grant indeed any
discussions on those
I think it's just the minutes it's just
a genome it wasn't the extraordinary
meeting
just a normal meeting not extraordinary
okay yeah that's cool got that later
all those in favor
I'll carry
extraordinary medium Council on the 12th
of September
yeah sorry so the twins twins have got
they thinking
Michael's writing that with his left
hand
any discussions on that
there being none and all those in favor
minutes of the community will be in
committee held on the 12th of September
with a two recommendations no one
recommendation
next year move that the minutes be
received and the recommendation adopted
thank you
Leslie thank you any discussions on
those yes great yeah just um with
respect to the master plan for Sandy
point in having a bit more time to
reflect on that
um I'm not sure that
the master plan
you know aligns with
what needs to happen at Sandy Point if
that makes sense and yeah
yeah I've obviously been thinking about
that quite a bit and
yeah I'm just I'm just not convinced
about that process so
oh sorry about that plan
if I may yeah just thinking ahead of me
I'm just going to say that
thank you man Clark so
um I think that's fine we were at at the
moment is about taking the master plan
and therefore the management plan
subsequently out for consultation
and as far as the consultation process
goes you can have a position and an
opinion but you want to hear it in an
open way and and I think if you've got
concerns or any counselor has concerns
or no people who have concerns you
should encourage them to feed into it
um because this this there are things in
there that that surprised me a little
bit and might not necessarily upset with
where I
yeah it felt the reserve had been or or
could be but
um I'll be interested to see what what
we get when we're receiving the
submissions on it so
um
we we had a lot of discussion around
police implications at the time and that
I think we've managed to resolve that
but
uh I'm on a let's see where it takes us
Journey but
I think with all of those things the
journeys were going with caution yeah
right okay so just as a flown from there
if if a council or counselors wanted to
write some issues about their overall
goals on there we did get focused on the
leasehold obviously
um you know about whether it should be a
recreation center or what the lien could
potentially be used for do they have to
signal that before the before the
consultation process or can they just
jump to that afterwards and then then
the community say why didn't you give us
some
so ultimately our input comes at the end
once submissions are received so I I
guess if you if you know of someone hmm
it feels the same way you encourage them
to submit and therefore that gives you
something to talk about to raise it as
an issue for us to discuss when we're
making the decision
I guess that that was going to be my
reflection as well because
and we get that four days before a
meeting and we're missing me not to read
it on the fourth day not the last day
but
um
when we got the presentation as well
from the consultant it sort of left me a
little bit hanging on them by about is
this where we want to take the overall
do we want it to be recreational as in a
recreational center what's the cost of
that going to be and I think that's
something we probably need a bit more
time to consider Yeah well yeah if I may
yeah it's a really really important
asset for our city I think
so it's an important document for us to
get right through and I you know
Community feedback will be valuable
but you know it's a very important asset
for a community yeah
okay
so you get one of your friends to
do a submission
asking for a friend yeah
it won't be one of the ones that walks
the dogs out there because you might not
be seen doing that by yourself
all right any further discussions on
that
okay so all those in favor
aye Carrie
and the last one is a proactive release
paper and I assume Michael you're going
to talk to that
thank you Mr Mayor
um assistant paper is a follow-on former
a paper I talked brought to Council in
July regarding airport released this
paper covers off the process that we
account to was involved in making this
decision to move in to uh public
excluded to receive reports and conduct
discussions
um
I probably don't need to say too much
more to that I think the paper is
relatively clear but I do need to point
out
um that it is the intention that when a
paper by staff is proposed to be in
public excluded that staff spell out the
reasons and that there is a proposed
release date there
um
occasionally
um you will see them come through as
blink we try
um and certainly I try when I approve
the agenda to correct those but look it
does happen from time to time it's not
ideal and at that time I would um be the
council would be able to make a
suggestion on when it considers
we consider the release of that paper
and with that I'm very happy to answer
any questions
ringy
I'd actually like to test the water here
um given the new a new tool in the
armament
right at the bottom it says counselors
at the meeting have the final right to
determine if the matter is received in
public excluded I like to move that we
bring the great Southland expectation
into public
's always been able to be moved that way
yeah this one test works it doesn't
sound like a lot of water steering no no
can we come out there
so I would I would say uh councilor
pottinger that
uh my paper's not quite the time to do
that but I certainly take your point I
thought that was a prompt
and that will be coming shortly after my
paper has been received okay right sorry
I'm happy to remove the recommend to
move the recommendations one and two
yeah you've lost me now
one's on the screen
leaving the report and noting the role
yes um so my view of that was we've
talked about this for a long time and I
I think
um that chairs including myself when we
get papers come through to us they're an
open by own PE should be automatically
looking at that not to release provision
which you're going to see an example of
shortly that's been left blank
when we get into PE
um and if we're not happy or the group
that we manage is not happy then we
should say so that otherwise it just
gets left for staff to make a value
decision when they're putting a paper up
or if it's left blank then Mike will end
up making a decision I think we should
take greater control of the of our
ability to um
to hold it and uh in for a certain
period or not
so um I'm just gonna I'm gonna just take
a breather for a minute and talk about
rangi suggesting that the letter
expectation comes
comes back into p and open
well it wasn't a signal
it's a matter of process we can imagine
um when we get to the end of this
session and before we go into PE because
the reasons will be given we're going
into PE if you wish to challenge that
then we'll uh we'll make a decision on
that I think I have an idea of My
Success
no I wouldn't have seen that because one
of one of the issues one of the issues
that we're going to face when we get to
peers that report where it says reason
for withholding and for how long is left
blank
[Music]
see that as you flip forward
so we'll have a discussion on on the
validity of holding it in PE as opposed
to having an opener
the decision is open then you'll have an
open
okay where do we get to Michael uh we
have a mover and a second down yep
um I believe there may or may not be
some discussion and then hopefully you
can put it to the vote Mr Mia yep any
further discussions about the paper put
up
there being none all those in favor
this is always fun
all right no it's it's more just a an
understanding piece so is this just
bringing us into line with other
councils or what's the purpose of sort
of doing this review at Tom is it just a
normal course for business or so the
proactive release was something that um
a number of councils are dealing with
but it was specifically brought to our
attention when the Ombudsman did his own
motion investigation into our leguma
practices yeah so it is bringing us into
best practice yeah this paper is simply
um adding to a part that I didn't
include in my proactive release paper in
July and then Mia quite rightly pointed
out that I've missed the part of
council's involvement and the leguma
process which is to move into public
included to discuss papers yeah so it's
democracy yes but we we have raised it
as elected members in the past yes once
again it just tends to stay there yes no
unless somebody comes looking for it
then you have to justify why you still
got it there yeah no thank you
any further discussion all right being
none all those in favor
aye aye Carrick now we get onto the
issue of moving in two
public excluded
and the reasons are listed there so I
won't go through all those but rangi you
want to move something about the uh
the paper at the end which is the letter
of expectation
no I'm fine
okay
I think you're quite right to ask that
question
[Laughter]
but I mean clearly there often would be
circumstances quite a lot of expectation
a discussion of that would include
commercial and confidence information
sure and nervous appropriate to go into
PE when I read this one specifically I
don't see anything in it yeah that you
would consider commercial and confidence
and I think it probably as appropriate
to do to judge these things in a you
know Case by case rather than have a
kind of it's a lot of expectation
therefore yeah
um I might be wrong and anybody else can
point over there maybe there is
something in it there's commercial
containers but I don't see it
so I'm happy to move unless anybody I've
seen
everyone
sometimes with things like the leaders
of expectation that as we're going
through we may mention other things
which
are commercially censored so it's not so
much even what this one sees it's what
some of the
um
conversation that wraps around at me and
you won't know until the end of the
process whether or not that applies
I'm open to either but I do think that
sometimes there may be things that we
don't tease out fully because we
suddenly become aware that we're getting
into a little bit of a a trap for
ourselves so
a technical question yeah is that a good
enough reason
no
no no and I think the fact that
something may be mentioned yeah well
it's always a risk isn't it and so it's
how much of a risk that this particular
issue raises but in letters of
expectation in general sometimes you're
talking about something else which is is
hidden for a good reason
um and it accidentally comes out of your
mouth
are we putting ourselves at risk and and
there's been a number of things over the
last few months where
unintentionally people have prejudiced a
different conversation
I've got a couple of people that want to
have someone there before I do that
though um I guess it's a balancing act
we've had nearly nearly an hour talking
to Great South and what underpinned a
lot of that is to the public in
particular don't know what goes on with
great sound
and the more transparency we have the
other better if we got something that
was
um triggered by commercial sensitivity
then that that's what we would hit I
guess
and would be guided accordingly and the
other thing is that sometimes when we
have stuff in PE we can release it
subject to just crossing out the bit
that is centered
redacting it so I think if we really
want to be transparent we should you're
on the side of being transparent
Michael's um oh sorry Darren
no excellent
oh cool I'll call you ringy next uh
Michael thank you through yourself
um Mia Clarke
I just highlighted um the reasons we're
into actually called out um
in in the clearest form and I do
apologize for that
um and also that the note about when it
when we would recommend release should
have been on there as well we would be
recommending uh reasonably prompt
release in relation to this post um
council's decision in relation to the
funding aspects
the reason we had this in commercial was
in relation to council to be able to
have a good strong discussion in
relation to the different funding
streams
um that relate to the contract with
great South this has a significant
impact in relation to the Staffing that
is at Great South
um that is why we want to have the
discussion uh in a from a commercial
sensitivity point of view but we would
urge on the point that we would want
this proactively released as soon as
possible anyway post this meeting
because it is it is something that we we
strongly believe should be public posts
then as well so we would agree with that
but we would like to have the what we
were wanting to have that discussion
with Council
um in a px form
so that big sequestion if Tom's right
there's nothing of a commercial nature
there then why are we using a commercial
center to be provision to
have it in PE as opposed to having an
open I mean one of the issues that I
mean I hear what you're saying Michael
about it might affect staff at Great
South well I mean at the beginning of
the year we we faced a
20 plus rate increase and we made some
tough decisions about what we would do
and we did them basically in in an open
manner so people could see that we were
cutting our cloth accordingly in a time
of High economic stress cost of living
impacts and all that sort of stuff and
uh
and we got as low as we could get with
the rate increase
why would why would our colleagues at
Great South be in any different position
that we are not going to give them any
extra funding or that's the outcome of
the letter of expectation
um then they have to make some decisions
about what they do with this now
and I think they're already geared up
for that but
no need for myself to comment on it okay
Leslie
thanks
to me
noticing that almost every one of the
recommendations
um
has
a significant choice of options involved
in it yeah all of which have monetary
factors attached to them and all of
which are going to
probably lead to some open comment
I probably would be more comfortable
to have this in committee with a very
quick release afterwards I'm just
looking at the number of those
recommendations that
are going to
um
have flow on effects
yeah we look we had we had a meeting of
this um for stakeholders of Great South
stakeholders recently and there were a
number of Staff members there which I
thought was a little bit unwise I'm a
great South Pacifica but all those staff
members all spoke they were senior staff
members who talked about the divisions
that they managed and we had got some
healthy discussion going about well if
we don't give you the money you want
because we've clawed back services in
our Council cut out cloth accordingly
how do we then justify to our ratepayers
that we've prepared to increase your
funding uh 10 15 20 it just doesn't sit
with rate bars and so we had that in a
quite an open environment the staff that
were there clearly got some messages
there was some unease about some saying
Hey I want to retain my staff for future
use but not current use and we had some
discussion about that too
even given that
version seven
point two point one or however you say
that
with brackets
um does mention industrial negotiations
which I am assuming in this case means
the potential impact on employment
matters then I think that we have our
conversation in public as recently has
said
and subsequent to the advice to Great
South board then it could be released
but it actually gives the Great South
board time as well to do the appropriate
Communications with whoever they have to
communicate with we shouldn't be doing
this through through the media we should
be doing it in a respectful manner given
that
there are staff at all levels at home
implicit in this
I guess we've got different views here
so the easy way to test it is I've got
uh
Tom and Grant Hoover and Cigna
Let's test the water
what My Views haven't listened yeah
I I don't have any strong feelings I'd
never arised it had rain you know it
raised it but when he did raise it and I
looked at it again I could not see
anything in there that would have been
commercially sensitive
um I I do hear what Evelyn and and
Leslie in particular has said in the
subject about here Luke there might be
and Michael that we might wish to
discuss things that would be constrained
particularly in maybe industrial
relations models that would be
constrained by Covenant in public
um I I I'm I understand that but I I
feel as though we're kind of searching
for reasons to take an epe rather than
doing what we're supposed to do which is
only put it in PE if it's essential
right so I'd be assuming we'd be kind of
flipping the the coin
um I I don't see those arguments has
been enough that we would that we would
put any PE so I I would I think I'll
still make that motion yeah
the point and I hear the point around
the stuff but they're asking for an
increase not a decrease
so on that very simplistic notion you
know the current level of funding
um and we're not suggesting we're
cutting it I don't think but you know
they're asking for an increase in
funding so I'm struggling to see how it
would affect staff if we're just holding
the funding at where we've been versus
increasing the funding I don't see here
you know
that translates to a reduction in staff
because we don't increase the funding it
just means you hold the staff at the end
of the water seat so um Michael was was
at that meeting as well and and look
this one not coming to a surprise to a
great show or any of the staff they they
went in there specifically if you think
about Beyond 20 25 14 work streams
currently we fund about six or seven
and Charmy said to us we want you to
show us your top priorities and we will
require to do that one through six so
that we know what we have to provide in
order priority if we don't get the
funding we want yeah so they're already
down the track with us they're aware
yeah so that's all I would have
any final discussion
okay all those make it easy to show
hands all those in favor of moving from
PE back into open
for the Great South later
real quick new account there
okay then we discuss it and open
all right can you make that happen
Slide the screen across
could you record my boat against it
please certainly
okay just remind cases you'll need to go
into the public excluded agenda now and
get this is the last item on that video
so you can discuss it now while we're
still in public we just moved back in
public
excluded
public yes we've remained in public we
haven't gone in about them excluded
and Mr
yeah
thank you Rihanna
cancerous
um so you'll recall Great South came and
met with you all a couple of weeks ago
um I went through all of these
resolutions for your consideration with
Charmy in detail the chief executive of
great sale
so um
I'll go through them
in order
um because there is a fair amount of
detail in there and in terms of why
they're put to you the way that they are
in order to inform and assist your
decision making
um in just a reminder in terms of time
frames The Joint shareholders committee
does need our feedback for the letter of
expectation following this meeting in
order that that can be issued by the end
of next month
so this paper relates to the ICC
elements that will go into that letter
of expectation and it is important to
consider in all these factors that
obviously the funding for great size
comes from another number of
shareholders and where there is
differing opinions between shareholders
as to what activities may need to happen
um
there may be funding shortfalls that the
council might need to consider if it
wishes activities to go ahead that other
shareholders do not wish to proceed with
so there is a number of different
funding elements that are included
within this report the first element
relates to the core funding the core
funding is set within the Constitution
by a formula that is based on population
statistics that formula is due for
review so it's important to take that
resolution or recommendation rather 3A
on the basis that this number will
or it is likely to change
um but essentially the figure that
you've got there is the ICC proportion
of the proposed great surf increase that
they need to meet their core costs based
on the current formula
so that's the first element that relates
to the core funding that we provide
Great South
that's the funding to enable them to
open the doors and to operate
so 3B relates to the contract funding so
this is the second type of funding that
we provide Great South and it's against
specific outcomes to enable them to
deliver a range of outcomes that Council
specifically wants them to achieve that
split across the areas of economic
development business development tourism
development and events development so
I've provided two options for your
consideration the first option is a
breakdown based on the current level of
contract funding that ICC provides great
sales and a mix for you to consider
based on conversations that have
happened around this table in terms of
priorities and so you could choose to
provide the same level of total contract
funding but divvy it up a different
amount across those areas of economic
business tourism and events development
the second option is a higher level of
funding that meets the requirements that
great South have indicated they have for
delivery of services so just to be
really clear this is not to provide an
increased level of service or higher
levels of outcomes it's to maintain
the current level of service that
great South provide
so you'll see that option two
is higher
um resolution
C is for you to provide any specific
narrative elements of priorities for
example focusing on a particular area of
economic diversification or on City
Center activities so that that provides
guidance to the great surfboard
then
um
the chief executive of Great South has
indicated that there are two further
elements of what they term business as
usual activity that they are requesting
funding for that's the coordination of
Beyond 2025 implementation and we've
taken an indecative 50 percent
so it's just an amount to indicate
amongst the primary funders what might
fall to ICC if we want that activity to
continue and then the same for
um 3E which relates to the additional
funding to provide for a Beyond 2025
Regional Data Center
so again Great South indicating they see
that as their core activities but it
lies outside of the current funding
structure of core and contract funding
and then moving on beyond that are the
potential priority areas for Beyond 2025
action and Associated support and so
those are all listed separately for your
consideration
those are the areas that have been
discussed by The Joint shareholders in
terms of regional strategic Direction in
the areas of of importance that the
great Southport believe they can add
significant value to the region
um so again those are for the council to
consider the extent to which that aligns
with the Strategic priorities that
Council has and the areas that it wishes
Great South to support in delivering
those strategic priorities
um so
in terms of working through based on
those resolutions above I recommend we
include an amount in resolution four in
order to note the total allocation of
funding that you as a council wish
to indicate to the Joint shareholders
committee that you are in a position to
provide Great South going forward
and then suggest that following the
normal process through the statement of
intent invite the Great South board to
consider would they recommend you
actually provide a different mix of
funding within that total funding
envelope to better achieve the outcomes
that you're looking to achieve
the other elements in the resolutions
relate to the technical elements in
terms of the
um approach to the statement of intent
and I'm happy to take any questions on
the report
um so maybe I'll just give you some
feedback start with Maria
um
I guess it doesn't sit well with me that
great South is asking for nearly 12
increase
given today's economic environment
is that the first thing I guess when I
go through the
options of d e in the suite of ones that
are an if I don't agree with any of
those
um and I'll tell you why because they
are built around traditional work that
they've done that I don't think they
should do anymore so they've probably
been funded for 10 15 or 20 years to do
work on housing for agum's sake and from
where I sit we've got no housing
outcomes all they do is collect data
and do reports for us
um on on the issue of
um the regional data center that's a
nice thing to have but in today's
environment
pulling together a database at click
Start from other databases is a nice
thing to have but not necessarily
something we need to have the direct
benefits for them to do their reports to
us as opposed to being direct for us
um I don't know why we would be involved
with supporting Forestry
and the water one where we're already
doing our alternative water things I
don't know how much great South will
contribute any more about that
um aquaculture I have some
tolerance for I guess land use I'm not
sure about
supporting energy it doesn't matter what
great South does it this renewable
energy is a central government issue
that's coming our way and I'm not sure
whether we'd want to do routing or
transport a bit of an odd mix those two
together given that roading means one
thing and transport means exactly
something completely different which is
what runs on the roads and certainly the
rolling issue is for the Southland
District Council they've got a high need
in that area
so why would be giving um
money in that era I'm not quite sure
anyway
um so that just might be on of the will
I think in today's environment we've cut
back
significant areas of Service delivery
which we did the last
rate strike we took a lot of money out
of our budgets to now give a nearly 13
increase to
Great South doesn't sit well with me I
just expect them to cut their cloth and
I found it really interesting at the
meeting that I was referring to before
that we went to
Steve keaney was here and he said oh you
know I need to keep the sauntings and I
need to keep that hydrologist and I need
somebody else to entertain me and I just
thought well hang on it might be nice to
have them and to retain them but if you
don't have a short-term need for them
why do you retain staff for that reason
and I guess the last thing is a lot of
this is built around
um their expectations that they're going
to deliver Beyond 2025.
and so a lot of a lot of the work
streams are in there councils should be
delivering that not not our Economic
Development agency they've done what
we've asked for them and we should in my
view just give them what we gave them
last year no more
about open to what other people might
think on there
Michael
getting in early yeah thank you for
yourself uh Mia Clarke um I just want to
highlight and send apologies to Great
South for the um comments probably about
to make in relation to the funding side
of it
um
one of the key things if you look at the
annual reports and their statement of
intents that have been in in the past
few years you will notice there has been
a funding aspect in relation to space
operations that has been in their
accounts to the tune of nearly half a
million
they they half a million has contributed
to their ability to fund certain
projects and offset some of the costs
associated to their staff in relation to
delivery of those
that funding is now not available due to
the statement of the tents that Council
has seen and has approved through there
which has a strategy to retain that
investment within space operations
that funding Gap equates to
a good portion of the 12 percent that is
being indicated as being an increase in
the funding Gap if you take that into a
get account at more than halfs the issue
that is being put forward so part of
that is to address that funding Gap
issue in relation to the statement of
intent
wanted to highlight that to give a
perspective in relation to the financial
position you see before you and the
information that you're seeing from a
commercial sense
and I guess my reflection is I don't
know whether many of the councils around
this table will know how many staff the
Great South has got you there'll be a
few that do but 40 yeah it's 40.
so that's quite a significant investment
um
anyway
Tom
um
I I for your chair
um I I struggled to figure out as I read
this what was additive and what was
actually you know the same numbers
quoted twice but if it is additive then
um you're 12 is actually it's actually
much higher than that because it'd be 12
plus items it'd be 12 on the core and on
the project if we take the nine hundred
and twenty thousand dollar option
but then it goes into a further between
um D and
dnf a father of four hundred and twenty
thousand dollars
which would be a new which is new money
so the amount of increases being sought
is much higher than 12 and and I haven't
actually tried to do the math but I mean
it's I won't have to it it must be at
least 20
um but I think we obviously recognize
when we look at uh that the additional
420 000 is the cost of um implementing
Beyond 2025. I don't know all right it's
it's all projects associated with Beyond
um through you chair yes but just to be
clear great self see two elements of
that the coordination in the data set as
core and including that within what
they're calling their business as usual
funding and then the other options were
the optional elements that the joint
shareholders Workshop worked through in
terms of great stuff could Implement
those for the region and so just that
speaks mayor to your point around what
is the role of Great South in that
implementation of Beyond 2025 I think
they've been quite clear that there are
many areas that others are leading
um they are currently coordinating the
implementation and this is what they are
indicating would be needed to help that
continue
but I guess if I can just probably ask a
same question a slightly different way
so
um Rhiannon am I reading this correctly
that the item D there the 110 000 I
might call Core 2025 it's to support
that teaming in it then goes into
e and the five items of f are individual
projects within Beyond 2025
so if I add all of those elements up it
comes to 420 000 new money which is
um
I think we have to reflect chair as well
I mean the automatic response I think to
that would be you know we're not going
to put all that additional money in but
this is the first year of Beyond 2025
implementation if we put nothing in then
all the work has been done and Beyond
2025 some may argue has been wasted if
there is no money put any implementation
so I'd I think we'd have to reflect on
it on and in that way I don't have a
proposal because an awful lot of money
but um but I don't think we can afford
to put nothing in to be on 2025.
so unless we prepare unless we're
prepared to just see we're you know just
skating that project I guess it comes
back to several things if you're looking
in our our recommendation if
and you the agrees disagrees there's
eight areas to support there if you're
telling them up
from my view we'd only want to support
two
and the other thing is that when you say
Implement one of the things that I've
long challenged Great South honors when
you develop a master plan like Beyond
2025 which is still a year and a half
two years away
um
do they implement it or do they hold us
accountable for what we need to do
within that plan
and so why are we paying for the
accountability
we should take our share of the plan and
do it
um and get on and get it done a good
example that recently is that we've had
some um
Lizzie and I and Tom have done some work
in the housing space which we know is
urgent
and we're getting pressure points all
over the place on housing now we've got
a master plan Beyond 2025
but we can't wait that long if we've got
new industry coming we need the houses
now we need them pretty quickly so we
need a picture government and other
investors that might get into this area
we can't sit around and wait but what
can Great South actually do to help us
build any more houses
and there's no disrespect to Bobby I
respect the work that she's done and
she's been into a couple of meetings
I've had recently over housing and end
up leaving because I don't think he sees
a role there for herself
she can't actually facilitate any of
this new housing stuff it requires
Council and government yeah some other
agencies
that is a question not here whether
um a green great size are a little bit
off to one side to people will be part
of the main game yeah but the whether
the the work which has been done by
Bobby you know where the work has been
done by Bobby still needs to be done by
somebody
um because it's going to be pulled
together by somebody that's a work that
you know Bobby has has tended to do
whether that well that's through Great
South or whether that's through the city
and by some other means I think somebody
is going to do that work I'm sorry we've
lost the live stream so we may just need
to adjune so we can
correct that issue the camera has frozen
for some
bizarre reason so I apologize for the
introduction but we could camera doesn't
want us to do that
again
we've lost all the cameras I don't know
because it's just it froze it a bit but
you can see my bald spot so I just kind
of hate it hey guys look even though the
picture's Frozen the sound has I'm still
working yes
to fix this for us
thank you
foreign
thank you for all of you joining us on
the live stream unfortunately our camera
has frozen we're going to have to uh
create a new live stream feed so if you
can come back in about three minutes you
will be able to join us again in this
debate we'll resume uh thank you and
we'll see you soon
great
um by the power that is it
we sorted don't say that they want a
pancreas
sorry okay Grant okay
ready to go all right so thank you live
stream viewers
councilor Campbell
yes
so just going back to where we were Tom
um
foreign
that's been had with the Beyond 2025
document is the issue of who's going to
deliver them it's all right having a
nice master plan but if you don't have
somebody put your hand up and said yep
I'll sort that housing out or I'll sort
something else then it just sits on a
plan and so the issue is if they've got
the plan together
and they do have designation of who's
responsible not the city's got some
responsibility for some of those work
streams
um
what more do we need do we want them to
have accountability that we actually
deliver well I don't think that's the
role of an economic development agency
I think it's difficult to have that
discussion me everyone was sitting in in
this code you know I I think the
question of where we
um how much money we are prepared to get
good at South and it might be that we
decide on an amount of money at the
maximum that we're allowed and then look
at how it should be divided up and what
projects I I mean I wonder whether this
kind of
whether it's in private makes no
difference this kind of forum can really
just make these kind of decisions it
might be we can disable it we're going
to give them a million bucks and no more
or wherever we decide
um but I think we need required another
meeting probably to be certainly how
that might can best be spent in
consultation with them yeah so
where are you going Patricia
I thought you're running away
it's the time are you suggesting laying
laying or later
okay so quickly they're quiet I suppose
that's right yes
so so this report Builds on the workshop
that we had with great South yep um and
the joint shareholders committee do need
from us the priorities in order to
include that within the joint letter of
expectation
um in order to give great staff Fair
time to respond
um with their draft statement of intent
okay
um there is also because it is an ltp
year the alignment with the ltp
budgeting process that's important to
consider
I've I've written the resolutions the
way that I have to give complete
transparency to yourself and Charmy and
I worked on them together in order that
you could see each element that they
were asking for further support so that
you could see the breakdown of where
they need the funding
um in order to inform your decision
making
um I certainly hear the recommendation
from the deputy mayor and that's why
further down the resolutions I was
suggesting you provide a total figure
um and then the next resolution seek
feedback from the board if they would
suggest a different breakdown
and they do need to understand for me as
a council as to where your priorities
lie you don't need to work down the
resolutions that the way that they're
laid out you could work backwards from
them
um
but that's just a background on why the
resolutions are written the way that
they are
sure I'll come to the internet ring so
just as a view on that um
Tom seducing was okay but for me sort of
not okay it's a little bit like saying
well we'll give them an extra 500 000
let's say
whatever the finger turns out to be
because we can afford it to me it should
be what do we actually want to purchase
and if we don't want to purchase any
more than what we're currently
purchasing
then you don't give them any more
there's the other way of looking at it I
guess
ringy oh look just regarding
um paragraph or section six I don't
honestly don't think there is no need to
have
um A or B they're considering that
they're both they both relate to
um
like B A relates to section 58 of the
act and
be released to 56 I think if you just
say
they have to comply with the local
government that covers everything I
think we're being too specific there
it's like telling a director of a
company he's got to follow the rules of
companies act you know I mean it's it's
common sense they are a CCO and they
should comply with it with the Local
Government Act I I think spelling it out
is not necessary I think slightly
unprofessional yeah
support their ideas so who was me
oh Alan yes
um yeah I just want to speak to us too
um as I read through this and based on
all the discussions that we've had I
think we were like ring you just said
we're being too specific on other things
I see everything in here
um
under um section B two one really
evidence Economic Development everything
that you've got on the register below
that business development tourism
development events development that's
all Economic Development
to me that should be the only thing that
they really are tasked with and um and I
would support a
you know across the living
adjustment but I sort of think that's
where it should be in my view
I don't think I don't think all the
things below that I think if you give
somebody a specific number then they'll
employ somebody
with that task but really I don't think
it's the edge what are you going to get
back but what are you going to get back
for with regards to housing for say
twenty four thousand dollars
or fifty thousand I mean what are you
going to get for that I don't think you
know
yeah or agriculture I mean
what are you gonna get for that for
the money for that is uh 65 000.
we shouldn't be specific they should be
just tasked with economic development
that's it and
provide
show us what what you do what you've
done I think yeah when I went to the
stakeholders meeting with the assets to
prioritize I think they were accepting
it's not our job no but that's how
Economic Development they were coming
from the other angle they were saying if
you don't give us any extra money we
will need to make some cuts on our
existing starting level or outcome level
which ones are your priorities to retain
we want results
you see you know so show me some results
yeah okay
Rihanna
I think it's
that
um
Great South are attempting
to be as transparent as possible to
their shareholders in terms of the
activity areas that they could work on
and that some and that this process is
intended to provide them with some
clarity because there is some elements
that are of interest to all shareholders
but there are some elements that are
only of interest to individual
shareholders and that has been the
reason for why the core and the contract
funding is separated in order to enable
each individual shareholder to indicate
their areas of Interest as as councilor
Arnold says the outcomes what they want
what we are wanting to see in terms of
results because otherwise it's very
difficult for great surfboard to deliver
what the shareholders want that's what
the letter of expectation is intended to
provide some clarity
I understand that but when you look at
two of those outcomes to support
forestry and water so putting aside
water and then on the next one you're
talking about land use which is really
about the carbon Forest which
everybody's nervous about
um
what outcomes we get if we
if we fund those errors
I mean that's the issue which is what
Ellen's writing you're purchasing a
service not just purchasing advice we've
already got the advice we know how many
how many hectares are currently running
per annum into carbon products we know
it's a mess but it the fix is not with
us the fixes with central government
um so how much more do we need from our
Economic Development agency to help us
get the facts
am I Leslie
thanks Mr Mia I was just wondering if it
might help Focus their minds a bit if we
dealt with one two and three A and B
agh
[Music]
and then Focus the conversation after
that
so if we don't once we've decided on the
on the option one or option two and
three a b it might help to focus our
minds on the well we have to do 3A
separately yes and so that's roughly a
12 increase which Tom Riggs is closer to
20. and Michael day has indicated that
that's that's due to
profits out of space Ops previously
being used
for Great South which no longer can be
used for Great Sound they need to be
retained or returned
and so the last round I think they put
500 000 into
further development of
space Alps which is an okay thing
development company
prior to that they were subsidizing
there
staff here is what a better word and so
now as as I said we've got that's what
our funding is and because they these
have gone up and played out much higher
up
my freaking assuming that yes so that
then leaves us with a dilemma that do we
agree to an increase of 11.9 percent
given today's environment what do we say
hey you need to cut your cloth
Brianna that's what I'm suggesting that
might be the first thing to work out
before we start
talking
about the other you know from
three
C to sort of whatever yeah so we do have
core funding in the other stuff yeah two
and three are you first so
um it is
Great South are indicating that they
need more funding to meet their core
costs if great for example and it
mentions that later in the report if for
example Council wanted to hold its
funding at the same level that it is
currently set at one option would be to
reduce the contract funding but Council
has a responsibility as a funding Class
A shareholder under a current formula to
meet the core costs that great South has
they are indicating that that core cost
has gone up
um so that would be one way of
approaching this is to say we need to
meet the core costs and then if we or if
you as a council want to ask them
to cut the cloth as you put it there
then it might be in the contract funding
I guess that and I'm just playing The
Devil's Advocate now
so that that's Cost Plus everywhere if
you take that mentality their core
funding will always be sitting there
with a cost of living adjustment going
forward but where's our ability to save
them well actually what are we getting
for our core funding as opposed to
focusing on the other list of things as
well
because that's what council had to do
recently
Tom
I I gave some
I'm probably going to repeat myself a
little bit but I mean if I was making a
proposal it would be that we agree to
the to their requested uh code funding
increase
and also they requested
um Project funding and Chris
but tell them that we expect that
project 25
2025 must be taken from
about monies because when I look at
project 2025 that actually falls into
the categories anyway I mean it's a bit
tourism and economic development I mean
as a kind of artificial distinction made
between project 2025 and the project
what they're doing
so I I guess you know for the sake of
getting a proposal on the table I would
propose that we agree to the
um 11.9 I think increase an increase to
907 900 and something thousand I think
that's another 11 percent
or not part of it
but that we expect that the project 2025
work is done within those totals
so let me teach you a little bit more on
that just on Play The Devil's Advocate
um
so one of the cool things for me is
beyond 2025 as a master plan developed
by Great South in consultation with
everybody and not a stunning piece of
work no doubling there and it gives
central government that also funds Great
South at times Some Way Forward
um
but do we expect our
development agency to actually deliver
that plan the 14 strands are within it
and I would argue they shouldn't deliver
anything it's back to us to deliver it
so what will their core role be going
forward
are they just going to drift off and do
some other work or are they going to
monitor your behavior
within those help come up given their
two years my personal view is that they
should have a scorecard type
accountability and
coordination rule somebody has to
um we will continually be asked whose
project 2025 gone and will be required
to you know by central government will
be required to comment back on that if
there's nobody pulling this stuff
together and I don't mean by that
leading it if there is nobody pulling
that stuff together then um we're never
gonna know how to answer that and and
you know her ability to access funds and
support some of these things in the
future is going to be it's going to rely
I think in an ability to answer those
questions okay
all right
Michael
thank you for yourself Mia um councilor
I'd just like to support my staff member
in relation to what she was saying about
the core funding
um I want to highlight that that core
funding doesn't actually actually get
you any outcomes um you should actually
be aware of that they're not providing
you with any outcomes from that server
that perspective that is the um the
executive team is their payroll team
it's their accommodation it's their
Finance team it's the back office
functions in relation to um great sale
um it is to keep the lights on and they
get nothing else from a service outcome
in relation to that
um your contract funding brings in all
of the people that actually get out
there and actually are doing all the
projects from that perspective and they
also get funding from other sources uh
to do even more projects for a Ministry
Etc I.E Great South or just transitions
component
um when they did did that component that
would be an example where staff are
being funded and managed through there
um and it is slightly offset by some of
the administration work they do for
other entities so they do get some
revenue and to offset some of that
um that is what the 11.9 uh cost is
indicating in relation to that
um You could argue that it's potentially
the cost of living component Associated
to their core funding uh
some of that will be in the past they
haven't quite had the right formula in
relation to their core funding and have
now got that right so some of the costs
that were should have been core have now
been corrected and reflected in here so
it's probably a catch up on some of the
previous school funding challenges that
had our finance team has gone through
that and accepted what's in in their
core Fund in this time around
so I just play the devil's advocate for
you again and I've got some other hands
up
um so most of the things you had on that
list Michael were people orientated
Personnel admin management payroll so
who's had a 12 increase in recent times
on payroll
through yourself and yeah um I also
highlighted there the accommodation
costs Etc as well
um which does go in hand with an
organization that's got more projects
going on they they need a bigger
accommodation and bigger admin support
so that'll be a proportion of that as
well okay I'll come to you shortly
listening about putting those motions
Evelyn
um yes because I did have my hand up
before but um
I think
addressing the real cost of running the
organization has probably been something
that they've needed to do for some time
and it has been masked by other things
that they were doing
also
having been hiring lately
I know that the real cost of hiring has
increased
so you replace a person you don't
necessarily get a cheaper person
often get a more expensive present
because the market is tight so I'm
comfortable with core
figure none of us likes to see big
increases but
this is a Professional Organization for
them to present professional outcomes to
us that needs to be accompanied by
the appropriate level of support and
accountability and if our chief
Executives is telling us that our
finance team have been through these
costs and I have been with them then I
accept that this is the real cost of
great self doing business on the behalf
of all this all the
um
Taylor um territory authorities and
environment southford and the community
as a whole so that's not the but that I
would be challenging if it were me thank
you grant
um
where do I start I suppose
I think or just looking at their report
so the this costs
um
for business services
23 24 482
000.
so
um
you know they're keeping the lights on
it
1.6 million when you roll up all the
funding seems a lot
so I wonder if that's actually correct
around it is employing Staff which will
do stuff
you know so we won't get nothing out of
it
and then the other fundings for
initiatives that are particularly
referenced around the contract funding
um
on I'm supportive of
um Essence Leslie's proposal around the
the core funding
piece
oh
increase and then if we hold the
contract funding at what it's been which
is 775 000 I think isn't it
that's correct I'm reading that right
aren't I
and then we tailor
what the outcomes because one of the
things I got through reading this paper
was I'm not really clear on what's going
to be achieved in each of those areas
for 775 000 so I'm absolutely
a lot we need to see that you know you
know I think if someone's said all
that's Business Development where any
effect it is
and so I know the different work streams
but it is all sorry Economic Development
so
I'm I'm supportive of the core funding
piece acknowledging that I don't think
it just keeps the lights on I think it
actually keeps you know people are
employed there and there will be stuff
be done that we output
um
in in we hold at our 775
which lessens the overall impact so the
increase is 11 on the core but overall
air increases much less which fits in
line with probably what our rates and
Chris was I would have said if I did the
mess
it's raining
um yeah co-funding Michael
um through the chair
um when you when staff casts the eye
over the court funding does it align
with this sort of methodology we use at
Council the way we apply costs
um and and and you know like the
essentials I mean obviously you have a
lot of experience in that and so it's so
do your staff
are they apples for apples
uh through yourself mere historically uh
we have used what we call General
Services as uh so we're very open from a
public perspective of what the cost of
our general Services is and we split
that out and show that that includes our
corporate services so we're we're clear
to the public
in respect of uh Great South as I
indicated before we've had
um
challenges in the past that we've seen
are an increase in cost coming through
in the last few years
um in their core costs and they have not
been reflected in what their
requested is funding from those cool
costs and that that's been small values
but it's small values that keep
increasing
um which have equated to a reasonable
increase on that
they are comparative to what you would
have from your core functions
um as in the ones I outlined before but
they
um
none of those none of those core
functions and the same it's from a
council perspective contribute to the
service output
From perspective of direct output they
do all contribute because you need to
make sure that your the staff on the
front line are getting paid and that
their health and safety and Etc is being
monitored so um
but they do contribute to the same cost
and they've got a similar cost profile
in relation to council and episode
thank you
seriously
um Michael's just giving me the
assurance that makes me feel comfortable
with Tom's suggestion that
you know lights on doors open basic
Services delivered at bit of
a at a level that is comparable with
what we would expect from our own
Council operation
um does justify the core funding figure
I must admit I was I was somewhat
attracted to Tom suggesting the option
two figure of 920 000.
um
was the the amount of contract funding
to go for and then to suggest that
within that larger figure
um we set the priorities that would
Encompass all of the material from D to
to G that's up there as additional that
that seems like a
perhaps a workable way of
of getting us further
I think if we if we go for the
complete
775 that's our current
we're perhaps pitching it too low to
really
get the sort of delivery we're expecting
in a number of areas
well it's a reduction in real towns
that's a well yes that was that was the
other thing I was thinking of saying
it's if we stick at 775 it is a
reduction in real terms and I don't know
that that's really
the message we
intend to be sending when we're asking
for significant delivery
so the way I see that the increase
that's requested for the
core and the potential for the larger of
the which is option two
um
for the contract funding it moves us up
about 180 Grand from where we are today
so that's what we'll be debating for yes
sir well I was just going to say when
you talk about core funding you know
surely those people that are there
providing that core funding or have a
job and their job is to provide Economic
Development I would have thought
we keep talking like that something
separate then you know you do something
else
I mean you just don't have stuff
for the role and then you pay them again
to do something yeah because they
already did a good job
so when you talk about core funding
sorry um
guess what Michael was saying before was
that um
Steve for argument's sake not anybody
won't have a Steve name but um
um
wouldn't be part of the uh wouldn't be
part of the core fund and the core
funding is the back office stuff so
that's
HR
um payroll management
costs like that the people are actually
delivering their services physically
doing the work the Bobbies of this world
are in the
contract funding
he's nodding yes that is correct
that seems excessive what's excuse it
the contract or the core the core
funding
but it might be if that's all that
that's what if it only provides that and
no Economic Development yeah
as soon as awfully awfully High
well I've worked in organizations before
that have been ngos and
I I would struggle with um a core
funding
um
being larger than the contract funding
let me
just doesn't sit right with me
it seems an awfully I mean I don't know
what the accommodation costs are so
that's that's a an unknown against that
right two last ones Pioneer and Darren
and then I'm going to put the uh and
then I'll put the motion just to do the
first three okay no I mean I was really
just wanting to say that I just thought
the core funding also was slightly on
the high side and
um
he's why I was sort of supporting Grant
here in in his comments that he made
around it and and I can understand the
increase because they're probably more
likely it will include other things I
think my other thing was around the
um option one and option two where you
see with when there was an increase
within the 920 it was quite interesting
to see that
they're split between business and
tourism where
the business development we were looking
at was 100k
and option two is only 105.
but when you look at tourism there was
like there was no actual
for me justification around the 250 to
to me the the
I was trying to understand what was the
increase in tourism
rather than business development
reduction of events
so through you chat
um you absolutely
correct in terms of that difference so
that's why and the report speaks to this
um option one or option two are
essentially coming from different
directions option one is based on the
letter of expectation approach that runs
every year in terms of you as a council
saying okay what are our priorities
and so as I've written in the report
I've put that break down there as a
starting point for you based on all the
historic conversations this Council has
had every year so for example
historically in the area of Tourism and
events this Council has varied from
other councils in the region as
prioritizing events more significantly
than tourism promotion because it's been
the view of this Council that events are
really really important for the city
particularly in terms of deriving
visitation and historically we have had
a lower focus on tourism for example
than fiordland where it's a really core
industry so
um tourism is increasing in importance
for the city but it's it's still not for
example one of the major major economic
drivers so it's a starting point option
one to reflect what historically has
been this council's position option two
is structured on a 50 percent
split of the costs that great South are
indicating that they need to meet and
again historically each year when Great
South have come and presented to council
they've said we need more money for
tourism development and often that has
come from either other shareholders or
from other sources of funding
um so that's why there is a significant
difference in the area of Tourism
development so
just in reflection to that I mean I've
sat in a lot of these debates
and um
I mean if we're paying roughly 50
percent of that and here shares
they're saying that the funding they
need to enhance tourism is 800 and
thirty thousand dollars
that's an awful lot of
people power I guess one of their words
and now I hear what the district's got
to say about that and in particular
around
what do they call it
um project fiordland or project piano
whatever it is Major push into that area
but you'd have to wonder
won't benefit we get out of Tourism yet
we've cut out the events down from 200
last year
to 172 which is only a small card but
so
are not wanting to speak to speak South
here I'm just repeat
ing presentations annually tourism
development the budget is not primarily
people although there are people it's
also the costs of delivering promotional
campaigns promotional campaigns for
tourism are expensive even if you run
them on social media so that's some
that's an important reflection now I
can't give you this specific amount
within the 800 000 that they've provided
to us but my understanding based on
earlier information is that's where some
tourism spend goes
um
and again your correct May option two is
lower because it's constructed a
different way it's saying 50 of their
total costs if you as a council wanted
to continue saying events are really
really proportionally important to our
Council
then you could indicate a higher level
of funding
alternatively you could take the route
that the um deputy mayor has suggested
and rather than going down line by line
and providing funding you can say here's
our priorities please come back to us
with where you would allocate the
funding I would just flag that is what
we worked towards this year it wasn't
um didn't eventuate that way but the
resolutions are written to try to
provide a pathway through what is a
really complex operation great stuff
does an awful lot
of work for the region which is quite
complex
so I know the resolutions are long but
that's why they're provided the way they
are to try to support your decision
making okay thank you so just as one
final comment from you there Ariana so
if we went down the path of sleeping
either one or two as Thomas suggested
and just left them in the four clusters
um we wouldn't need the the remaining
Suite of things to say agree or disagree
all the way through I I would still
recommend and sorry would you mind
sitting down this
I would still recommend that you oh
sorry a little bit further out
[Music]
um
let me just find the resolution number
but I would still recommend that you ask
the Great South board to provide you
feedback
which is sorry it's resolution five
because you're essentially saying this
is our view now please tell us your
feedback
which is the statement of intent process
and it wouldn't be a different breakdown
would it because we wouldn't be
proposing a breakdown
would be asking if your oppose a
breakdown not a different breakdown
well if we accept option two we're
accepting the one two three and four
that's in there that we would be asking
great self then if we then passed
um the the later number four
um or sorry number five we would be
asking great self to come back and
suggest a different breakdown
considering the total figure
Great South might very well come back
and say with them at 920 we would
actually take some out of Tourism and
see it as a higher priority that there
is a regional Data Center
development continued or whatever so we
would actually be asking Great South
within within an envelope
to come back to us under five and say
he is a refined level of
reply from us within that envelope
we did include the 2020
yes and that could include them saying
we really think that that the um 2025
implementation
through the the data center or any of
the other aspects are so important that
we're coming back under number five and
saying this is a suggestion
Rihanna so I would recommend that you do
include the guidance to ask for the
board feedback for two reasons both the
reason that the Great South board has
the board members it does is because
they're recognized as being experts in
business and economic development so you
want their feedback specifically which
we have requested but um within the
clunky SOI process haven't always got
effective kind of feedback that's really
helped your decision making and secondly
the and the other aspect of complexity
which both the Great South board and all
the shareholders are dealing with is
that there are multiple shareholders
involved here by asking them to give you
further feedback you're enabling them to
flex if one of the other shareholders
says actually we can't fund this at all
so um 50 may not be enough for example
or one of the other shareholders may say
we really really value this we want to
put all our funding into tourism
um by asking them to come back and say
recommend a different option you're
giving them flexibility to say we've
actually met our funding via a different
mechanism for this we would request ICC
for example please put some more money
to be on 2025. so that that's why I
recommend including so before we go to
the vote on on three A or B
you've got those options one and two on
it
those fingers we've got in here so if it
was option two at 9 20.
Watson C through
to
if is all additional to the 920
because when you consider that before I
said the 180 what's the difference
between last year and this year that
does not include anything that's in that
agree disagree agree disagree so you've
got to add that in as well
Michael uh throw yourself from here
listening to the room
um I would suggest that if you're
wanting to go down that front you could
go agree uh for example
a greatly support Agriculture and land
use funding to come from contract
funding
you can take out the dollar terms and
you're putting back a signal to Great
South that you want it to come you want
to support it that you want it to come
from contract funding yeah you don't
want to provide an additional Fund in
relation to it
absolutely so just for clarification
Michael are you suggesting we could we
could pass the core
to 2066
and then the contract at 9 20.
but take out the the suggested split of
that 920
villain number four with the total
figure of 2986.
and then ask under five that great self
comes back to us with a suggested split
of what we would be saying is a total
figure of 2986. and they could then come
back and suggest
the C to G
priorities we should consider within
that envelope that is correct uh
councilor however I'd suggest you might
want to look at whether you agree or
don't agree to support the um different
things like housing and Forestry as part
of that component so send a message back
to correct yeah I think that's important
so just so should I think that's a good
point so should we
can we pick off those agree or disagree
which then gives form to
if
we go faster because I've got to go on
surely yeah
so just just for the point of clarity I
just done some quick calculations there
if we were to support everything on
these agree disagree and rein and saying
we don't have to agree to all of them
yeah funding last year was 1.68
um and that would move the combination
of core and contract up to 2.15 yeah so
that's half a million dollars rather
than great
what I was proposing was that we
approved the nine hundred thousand yes
let's say that that must include
essential 2025 Beyond 2025 work yes
another 300 or something like that for
Beyond 2025 yeah and then it'll take a
further Direction around agree or
disagree then they can come back to us
with the priorities but to be on 24.
within that cap funding of 9 20. yeah I
mean we could express and prose what we
particularly support and Beyond 2025 but
as soon as you put numbers in if you if
you put those numbers in you end up
reducing you end up telling them how
much can be done for other ones that's
right yeah so we're just very disagree
not with the numbers no numbers yes no
numbers and then adopt your proposal
which is 920 which captures all your
contract funding and which includes your
tourism the 775. plus those agree or
disa whether the agreed principles out
of 12 24 uh Beyond 25
and and that gives very good direction
hearing rhiannon's Point around
okay we've increased your core funding
we've given you 920 to deliver
contract funding including these agreed
Beyond 25
priorities for us and we might only vote
one of those they may come back to us
and say look we can't do it for that
that's fine that's another discussion
for another day but at least we've given
them Direction and we've sort of ring
fenced what funding we're going to give
them and we're inviting them to come
back in under five we're asking them to
come back and suggest a different
breakdown yeah that's right with some
pretty clear results from us sorry to
factor in your costs and I'll be you can
get 920 plus your million and whatever
it is
yeah it's cool funding yeah so you're
two million yeah
yeah so it's two two nine is the total
um
just just to provide um Clarity that 2
million in the court is the total our
costs underneath are just over one
yeah
yeah yes
under this proposal which gives the
increase okay so Michael's giving us a
little bit more guidance on that so if
we um don't agree with C onwards at this
stage or we don't put any dollar amount
to it as Thomas suggested if we just
take option
two
and the core funding will end up at
about 1.94 which is about which includes
260 000 more than we funded them last
year yeah
yeah yeah which one close to 2025 so so
if you wanted to come back from that you
could go with the same proposal yeah
with the core and the 775 but the 77 775
needs to include of course the economic
development plus the agreed yep um
Beyond 25 ones that you want to agree to
that would pull it back to 1.7 yeah
which is an increase of about a hundred
and what's the increase of 108.
yeah otherwise we just if we took all
those agreed as agrees we put another
320 on time
okay I'll put I'll
got nobody else on this oh Darren did
you want to say something
no thank you yeah I think I'd rather
vote okay right that's not gonna add
anything at this point so um
so I I'll put uh one two and three a to
start with and then we'll come back and
have a separate vote on the B which
gives us the other options so Leslie's
already put up a mover on that Cigna
yeah thank you so we're just voting on
uh the recommendations one two and three
a which puts out 12 11.9 increasing into
core core funding yeah all right all
those in favor
anybody vehemently opposed Rangers you
want it recorded yeah yeah yep thank you
okay now on to options 3B and Beyond so
we've I guess we've got
um two options here we go for option one
or option two
and we can add
the subsequent agrees and disagrees
Beyond are those two if you wish it
seems that most of the discussion around
the table is to go for option two
without any agrees or disagrees there
Beyond and let them come back to us
not about that
nodding up here yep move thank you yeah
Grant seconded
all those in favor so we're voting for
option two yeah which is uh 920 000
which pushes their costs off about 260
from last year which is a significant
chunk
uh but we're not agreeing to add this
stage to any other
additional funding beyond that half
percent
of rates or what
without necessarily agreeing with the
one two three four breakdown underneath
that so we're saying option two is a
figure of 924. I'm opening to the movers
and signatures if they want to one of
the discussion about that whether we
live in option two was option to be in
the um
first line of option two yeah
um with a full spill past I mean twenty
thousand
and I think we should then
use Pros
further than doing in the letter to
describe the issue around this is
expected him being all-encompassable
Project work including
um project 25 and invite they may come
back and see how that baby split yeah so
I would just finish the sentence at 9 20
000.
so um
so you wouldn't have the one two three
and four below no but I'd use some
proofs for them
numbers what rhianne was talking about
before where we might ask for more
funding in the events development as
opposed to the tourism one foreign
I think it's absolutely an appropriate
way to proceed on option two to not
break it down
um but I think you should request that
the board provides their breakdown and
they have given feedback previously
a lack of kind of clear priorities from
Council makes it very difficult for them
to respond and provide a plan that meets
your needs now I think going this way is
very appropriate you have employed a
board with expertise but you do need to
be aware that they'll recommend what
they think
needs to be done and you may not
agree
so it's just important to be aware that
if you don't tell them what your
priorities are then they
should come at it with their expertise
and they may tell you things
that you don't know do you know what I'm
trying to say I could to lead the fourth
year and just take out the dollars and
those around forever
what we're wanting the Frozen support
areas of coverage I would just my view
would be to meet the deputy Mez
priorities is to just simply change it
to option two 920 000 requesting the
Great South board to indicate where that
funding would be allocated across
economic business tourism and events
include the additional line as suggested
we would also want to see beyond 2025
outcomes as possible within this amount
yeah I think
yeah exactly yeah
and then we then we pass or we we put up
resolution four and five resolution four
being the total figure with agreed to
and resolution five being the invitation
to Great South to come back
yeah
yeah and I also think rangi was right
about 6A and six
just a statement they comply with the
local government yeah yeah
can I just
you got all that oh Michael can can I
just say there that
I actually don't think it's a bad thing
to remind any organization that we as
shareholders expect to know surprises
approach that's right and I also um
think that it's a timely reminder that
we would expect
ahead of establishing any other trading
organizations that they would um see
shareholder agreement from the class a
shield as I actually don't think they're
bad reminders to well if you're going to
include those I've got about 20 others
you could put in there out of the act
that they should follow
me and you afterwards happens in the
last few months I'm not surprises remain
doesn't unnecessarily a lot of things
I mean Chrome accomplished when they get
letters for the ministers as I used to
get always includes that no surprises
even though you know we're supposed to
understand the actor always says and
unfortunately unfortunately Great South
report to the shareholders committee and
that's not us now we don't know what's
happening no really we don't
so a lot of stuff knobby may get to know
yeah but we won't we don't get that so
uh yeah
what's your proposal to remedy that
yeah
well 6A says no surprises approach when
the Great surfboard
and shareholders come as commend Class A
shareholders we are class A shareholders
we're asking for a no surprise to come
down I can give you a loaders yeah
should we treat it like okay where we
ask them to come back to us quarterly
yeah
their directors come and talk to us
quarterly yeah
what have I missed nothing oh sorry no I
was just going to speak to the quarterly
issue
we've got a motion
proposed amended by the Mover by
assuming the secondary is supportive of
the change in red
we had taken the door with it
um
do you want me to speak to that question
about the quarterly we can't do
um I think it's really important to be
aware the holding company really only
has us that they need to report to Great
South has many shareholders they have a
really kind of
broad stakeholder base
um
a lot of people to get around so can
they not have us all my roommate well
they do do that in terms of their
regularly they don't they have it I
think in the agreement it's three times
a year at the moment
so I just think it's important to be
aware
to be fair to them they have many
shareholders
yeah I can solve them there yeah
okay not everyone
um just that it's redundant to have
include the cost of Beyond 2025 to be
included within the swinger don't leave
out the two be included because
it's implicit within the whole sentence
thank you more of that really yeah I do
think you need the implementation word
in there of Beyond 2025 implementation
all right all those in favor of those
sweeter
which was uh option two
say aye aye
anybody opposed rangi recorded thank you
hello Michael
oh yes and six yeah
okay it's four and five and then we can
discuss six again well let's just do it
now let's just do it well I'll move four
five and six I think yeah all those in
favor I I carrying anybody opposed
no
I would like to move that we're going to
PE thanks Darren thanks Lucy
that's a good discussion